[Music]
is Bane a dark reflection of who Bruce
could have become if it followed a
different path does Alfred really see
Bruce in Florence we're here to shed
some light on the final points of the
Dark Knight risers picking up 8 Years
After the Dark Knight Christopher
Nolan's thirdd installment introduces us
to a mostly peaceful Gotham City a
tormented Commissioner Gordon and a
reclusive Bruce Wayne who stopped being
Batman after framing himself for hary
Den murder buts after C burglar Selena
Kyle steals Bruce's mother's PS the
mercenary Bane arrives and recruits the
young men of Gotham to his cause to tear
down the city Bruce Dons a cape and cowl
once more only this time he fails after
Bane breaks his back Bruce is taken to a
middle eastern prison to watch MAA as a
former League of Shadows member
dismantles Gotham from within separating
the city from the mainland Bane turns
Gotham into a No Man's Land ruled by the
people of course that's all a mirage as
Bane's men are parading a nuclear bomb
throughout the city with a mysterious
trigger man at the readying with Batman
away detective John Blake a man who had
previously deduced Batman's secret
identity steps up to help defend Gotham
in the dark Knight's absence but one cup
and an underground resistance aren't
enough as Bruce heals he eventually
succeeds in escaping from the prison and
returning to Gotham for a rematch with
his latest Nemesis even if it means his
death by the time Bruce returns to
Gotham the nuclear weapon is
deteriorated to the point where it's set
to detonate any day alongside his allies
Gordon Blake and Ela Kyle who has since
repented of her own role in all of this
Batman takes to the streets with an army
of Gotham police officers to take back
the city from Bane and his men the
Gotham police force overpowers Bane's
men while Batman disarms Bane and
demands the trigger where's the trigger
where is it only Bane doesn't have it as
it turns out Bruce's onetime lover and
Wayne Enterprise's Ally Manda Tate is a
real Mastermind behind Bane's plot
unbeknownst to Batman Tate's real name
is Talia al ghoul making her the
daughter of Bruce's former Mentor razal
goul after Talia betrays Bruce Selena
rescues the cape Crusader and helps him
track down the nuclear weapon Batman
takes it upon himself to fly the Warhead
out into the Atlantic Ocean and allow it
to detonate far away from the people of
Gotham as the city honors Batman Lucius
Fox Alfred pennyworth Jim Gordon and
John Blake honor Bruce's sacrifice but
as it turns out Bruce didn't die after
all after handing the keys to the
Batcave over to Blake Bruce Bruce and
Selena relocate to Italy where Alfred
watches from afar the last minute
revealed that Miranda Tate is actually
the daughter of Bruce's original Mentor
turned Nemesis through many for a loop
throughout the film a story is told
about a child born in a middle eastern
prison the child of Raz Al gou who
climbs up and out of the pit for a long
time the movie leads one to believe that
Bane is the child longtime DC Comics
fans likely saw this twist coming the
most prominent child of razal ghoul in
the Batman comics is Talia the who also
happens to be Bruce's on again off again
lover in fact aside from having led the
league of Assassins an alternate name
for the League of Shadows Talia is also
the mother of Batman's son Damen Wayne
the current Robin of course in the Dark
Night Rises Bruce and Talia only spend
one night together and their passion
doesn't result in a pregnancy though
Talia isn't mentioned directly in Batman
Begins the first of Nolan's Trilogy
alludes to razal ghoul having a family
of his own no wonder that Talia would
eventually return to reenact revenge on
the cage Cru Seda who she holds
responsible for her father's death from
the moment Bruce is first robbed by
Selena he becomes immediately infatuated
with the elusive cat burglar in a way
Selena is the one who inspires Bruce to
become Batman once again and she's by
his side when he first confronts Bane
sure she betrays him in the process but
all sins are forgiven when she sides
with Batman post Revolution no wonder
these two end up together in the end
each bringing out the best than the
other like your girlfriend Mr Wayne he
should be so lucky though Bruce spends
much of the Dark Knight trilogy pining
after his childhood friend Rachel dors
the Revelation that she had moved on
before her death opens a door for
budding romance with Catwoman more in
line with the relationship between the
two in the original DC Comics The Dark
Knight Rises makes Catwoman a bit more
3dimensional and complicated than
previous incarnations while it may seem
strange that Bruce and Selena end up
together it's worth noting that they
both bring much needed excitement to
each other's lives and while they come
from vastly different backgrounds they
quickly learned to better to understand
the other no wonder Matt Reeves played
on this again in Batman's next solo
outing 2022 is the Batman Christian
bal's Batman certainly has an exciting
Rogues Gallery scarecrow is a constant
thorn in Gotham's side razal Gul nearly
destroyed the Wayne family Legacy and
Two Face sent the Caped Crusader
underground of course few would disagree
that the Joker was the most impressive
and most deranged criminal that the Dark
Knights ever encountered you have
nothing nothing to threaten me with have
nothing to do with all your Str however
Bane breaks our hero like no other not
only does he Crush Bruce's Body but also
his soul he would have broken Batman's
Spirit too had our hero not risen above
his pain in many ways Tom Hardy's Bane
is a dark mirror of what bal's Batman
could have easily become likewise
trained by razal ghoul as a member of
the League of Shadows Bane's airus to
see Gotham burned to the ground so that
it can be restored completely motivated
by talia's drive for vengeance in Batman
begins Bruce felt a similar pull and
nearly killed the man who killed his own
parents he actually might have pulled
the trigger if someone else hadn't done
it first instead Bruce ends up taking
the path of the hero hoping to inspire
others to be the same of course Bane
inspires a group of loyal followers too
he even incites many of Gotham citizens
to turn on one another exposing the
city's darkest secrets and challenging
the status quo if it seems like Batman
and Bane work from the same Playbook
it's because they do they each use what
razal gold taught them which makes Bane
all the more dangerous you you're evil
I'm necessary evil
no one of the biggest debates among fans
is whether or not alfa's encounter from
afar with Bruce and Selena at the very
end of the film is real or in reference
to director Christopher Nolan's previous
hit Inception only a vision of what
might have been the case for it being
nothing more than a Daydream is a
compelling one at first glance there's
no way that Batman could have survived
that nuclear explosion right when would
he have jumped out of the bat did Alfred
just imagine it all of course there are
actual answers to these questions for
starters the movie explains that Bruce
fixed the bats autopilot off screen
which would have allowed him to bail
long before the explosion there's also
the fact that his mother's pearls are
missing from Wayne Manor pearls which
Selena had grown accustomed to we also
know that Bruce knows about Alfred's
yearly pilgrimage to Florence so it
seems that Bruce wants his surrogate
father to know that he is okay or
without saying a word lending his
thoughts Christian Bale believes that
Bruce's happy ending was genuine he
explained to Entertainment Weekly I find
it very interesting and with most films
I tend to say it's what the audience
thinks it is my personal opinion no it
was not a dream that was for real and he
was just delighted that finally he had
freed himself from the privilege But
ultimately the burden of being Bruce
Wayne speaking of Alfred it seems odd to
many that Bruce's surrogate father would
leave just when he needs him most
goodbye Alfred
sure Bruce tells him to but we never
imagine he'll actually abandon Batman
though All Is Forgiven by the end of the
movie it's still strange that Alfred
isn't involved in Batman's Last Stand
but when you consider how much Alfred
has had to tolerate over the years and
how much he cares about Bruce it may
just make sense after all the question
of what Bruce has to give to be Batman
hangs over the entire trilogy but Rises
finally addresses how much Alfred is
willing to give to help with Bruce's
Quest Christian Bale reflected to Empire
in 2020 Alfred asks how long is this
going to go on for it's not going to be
forever is it that to me has always been
fascinating about Bruce Wayne and
there's no secret in the dark and Night
Rises we come back to the original ideas
of what's happening in here it circles
back what b means is that Alfred has
always wanted what was best for Bruce he
just didn't believe that Batman is it he
always supported Bruce's efforts to
defend Gotham but never at the expense
of Bruce himself turns out that going up
against Bane is too much for Alfred to
handle though he regrets leaving by the
end at the very end of the movie It's
revealed that John bl's legal first name
is actually Robin a clever surprise and
nice nod to Batman's longtime comic book
partner of course there have been a
plethora of robins over the years and in
many ways it seems as if Blake is a sort
of amalgamation of a few of them an
agile orphan like Dick Grayson an angry
Street kid like Jason t and a skilled
detective who deduces Batman's secret
identity like Tim Drake Blake fills a
role of Batman's sidekick to a tea when
the movie ends Blake joins a
long-standing robin tradition of
graduating from The Dark Knight sidekick
to becoming the Dark Knight himself all
three of the aforementioned robins have
become Batman at some point in the
comics and others such as Damen Wayne
may do the same in the future as Rises
ends Blake locates the Batcave and is
ushered into Bruce's old life set to
take his mentor's place as a hero Gotham
deserves while we won't ever get to see
Blake's version of Batman hit the stre
director Christopher Nolan leaves his
Dark Knight Saga open-ended on purpose
to keep the legend of Batman alive while
it's unclear if Blake will become the
next Batman himself or Forge his own
superhero identity Gotham is no doubt
safer in his hands the initial trailer
for The Dark Knight Rises splices a
philosophical quip from Raz Al Gul with
clips from the first two installments of
the trilogy which ultimately sums up the
underlying message of the entire thing
if you make yourself more than just a
man if you devote yourself to an ideal
you become something else entirely a
legend Mr Wayne in Batman Begins Bruce
constructs the legend of Batman he
trains his body and his mind to become
the crime fighter that Gotham needs even
if he's not the hero they deserve and
saves his City by thwarting razal
ghoul's plan and killing him in the
process Batman becomes a living myth who
inspires gothamites everywhere and by
the dark KN Batman has fully established
himself even inspiring hockey pad
wearing copycats and Theatrical
criminals like the Joker to come out to
the woodwork and make their own mark on
Gotham this town deserves a better class
of criminal and I'm going to give it to
him by the time Rises ends Gotham
finally recognizes what the Dark Knight
has done for them and honors him in the
form of a statue but that's not all
Blake's decision to take on Bruce's
mantle pair with the repairing of both
the bat signal and the bat's autopilot
keeps the legend of Batman alive even
after Bruce Wayne dies ultimately Batman
lives on and that was always the
point
[Music]